officers down in front of the bank  automatic weapons being fired  [Music]  you want a driver cannot drive  bank robbery suspects have taken an  ambulance  i got a cop shot just got to get him to  the hospital we're doing hostages now  i came to you for a loan you're my  brother have i ever gotten you anything  that i couldn't get you out of lock  everything down  we're just trying to get home  we don't get to walk off into the sunset  i have a plan  police are following these two suspects  just chill out  gotta chill out hit me up  what's going on in there  these guys are nut jobs right here it is  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  hey what's up big guy just waking up  does your wife know your raw banks  [Music]  i'm sorry brother i think it's the best  of me  sorry that brought you into this  i just wanted things to be the way they  used to be we are trying to save you  [Music]  i'm gonna get you back home now brother  [Music]  and get everybody home  only in theaters april 8.  you